if you need some help satisfying your
true-crime itch and sifting through all
the titles online then grab your
magnifying glass and prepare to do some
investigating as we look at the very
best true crime movies and documentaries
that Netflix has to offer in 2007 while
on vacation with her family in Portugal
three year-old Madeleine McCann
disappeared from her bed and has never
been seen or heard from since Madeline's
case has resulted in a multitude of
theories and tons of speculation
regarding who was responsible for her
kidnapping was it an unknown predator
were her parents Kate and Jerry to blame
I think that's the feeling here was they
lied to us they were lying to all the
world there are conspiracy theories
galore about what happened here and the
disappearance of Madeleine McCann takes
on the enormous task of examining
Madeline's abduction from the moment she
and her family arrived at their overseas
resorts to the ongoing investigation not
only does the series offer an in-depth
timeline of events but it also discusses
the police investigation Kate and Jerry
McCann's media campaign to find
Madeleine and the potential theories
surrounding the abduction sister Kathy
says Nick was a nun and teacher at
Archbishop ko High School in Baltimore
known for her kindness and dependability
sesnick was loved by everyone who knew
her so when she failed to return home
one night in 1969 it was obvious that
something was wrong
tragically suspects body was found in
early 1970 but for years the nuns case
went unsolved that all changed in 1992
when a former ko student came forward
and claimed that father Joseph Maskull
the school's chaplain had sexually
abused her from there authorities dove
into father maskull's backstory
uncovering a history of abuse and a lead
and says Nick's tragic passing this
twist detail is documented in the
keepers a 7 episode series that dives
into says Nick's case and the
allegations of abuse that occurred at
Archbishop ko High School this series
explores the notion that says thinks
murder is directly connected to the
claims of abuse and the show does an
excellent job untangling the various
testimonies timelines and theories
associated with the homicide the keepers
is thoroughly engaging but it's also
deeply emotional and difficult to
stomach it
story of homicide abuse and cover-ups
but most importantly it's about a
community of survivors coming together
to find justice both for sister Kathy
sesnick and for themselves Ted Bundy is
one of the most well known serial
killers in American history thanks to
both his brutal crimes and his bizarre
behavior throughout his trial his
psychopathic insanity has been captured
for the whole world to see and
conversations with a killer the Ted
Bundy tapes is hard for me to believe
that what I did is newsworthy released
on the 30th anniversary of Bundy's
execution the Ted Bundy tapes recounts
the man's life including his crimes
escape attempts and eventual execution
via the electric chair
but what separates the Ted Bundy tapes
from every other movie and TV show about
The Killers crimes is the
never-before-heard audio interviews with
Bundy himself the Ted Bundy tapes is a
chilling experience because we know that
Bundy is in fact responsible for the
crimes of which he was accused hearing
him speak as if he'd done nothing wrong
is both an aggravating and horrifying
experience
and the next activity
or the nest in each interview it's clear
that Bundy's manipulative nature is at
play and he's attempting to sway
listeners with every word if you're
interested in learning how a maniac
charmed so many people the Ted Bundy
tapes is definitely worth a watch in
December 2015 the documentary series
making a murderer was released on
Netflix and almost immediately it became
a massive hit it garnered attention from
big names like Ricky Gervais Alec
Baldwin and Mandy Moore on social media
the series even inspired viewers to take
action in the form of online petitions
but why did this documentary impact so
many people the series follows the story
of Steven Avery a man who served 18
years in prison for the attempted
killing of Penny Bernsen with the help
of the Innocence Project Avery was
released in 2003 after DNA evidence
proved that he was not responsible for
the crime however two years after his
release Avery was convicted of killing a
second woman named Teresa Halbach so is
avery guilty of either crime or is the
man getting railroaded by the system
what happened
the first season of the series is mostly
interested in trying to prove Avery's
innocence and it makes a compelling
argument regarding the handling of his
case the second season focuses more on
Avery's lawyer as she attempts to prove
his innocence while having to navigate
every legal battle imaginable the
controversial show is wildly popular and
if you're wondering why now is the time
to find out in the 1980's a
controversial Indian guru named Bhagwan
Shree Rajneesh founded the religious
movement
Rajneesh Purim when the community moved
to a large piece of land in Wasco County
Oregon with the intent of creating their
own City the neighboring small town of
Antelope decided to fight back not only
was there resistance from their
neighbors but Rajneesh and his followers
faced constant legal battles and media
backlash that threatened their entire
community it would all lead to the
largest bioterrorism attack in US
history an event documented in one of
Netflix's very best series wild wild
country someone is out there who poison
an entire town wild wild country gives a
voice to Rajesh's followers as well as
the residents of Antelope by
interviewing members on each side of the
conflict we could an in depth the view
of how the community came to exist what
life was like for them and an
examination of the prominent figures
involved the series paints a vivid
picture of the events that transpired as
the community attempted to create and
hold on to their utopian commune at any
cost
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one